i have to ask you a tough question about
rachel you got to be very careful about
what you're doing on social media i have
a responsibility to
the women that are here to brittany
to myself
[Music]
to follow my heart matt i thought
that you handled everything last night
so beautifully
how do you feel anything you would have
done differently when managing
the toxic situation that had built up in
the house you know i think you can only
act according to what information you're
working off of and when
rachel and katie made that information
uh apparent to me then
it was on me to take the next steps and
i for me it's about creating a safe
environment for
all the women in the house so that we
can really connect with one another and
that's what i felt like we did last
night here's the love
it's been a little hard as a viewer to
watch
and figure out who isn't involved in the
toxicity
which women would you say you can
confidently say we're not part of
that bad behavior yeah you know what i
i wasn't taking tabs on it i um
every time i guess michelle you know
michelle wasn't involved in anything
every time
uh i spoke with michelle it was super
intentional and it was about our
relationship and
we're trying to catch up on lost time
same with ryan you know i guess so the
new women
uh who came later on in the journey i
never
uh saw anything up into this point about
them being
negative or toxic in the house so it was
refreshing to be around them
well the real question the real
questions are gonna be about queen
victoria
i honestly feel so sorry for you that
you would listen to hearsay and not all
of the facts
behind a situation so
goodbye matt what was going through your
mind at the rose ceremony when you'd
sent her home and she's just standing
there
chewing you out and you just didn't say
anything
lauren i was out of juice i had no more
words like i just i had nothing for
like i just i didn't there was nothing
in the tank i just
at that point of the night i just had
nothing she then
said to the camera never dating another
mat as long as i live ever i hate that
name now it's unfortunate a lot of a lot
of mats are gonna miss out on a queen
and um they're gonna have to that's
something they're gonna have to take on
the chin
how do you feel about victoria right
here right now
today i feel like i dropped the ball i
had an opportunity there
where i misread the opportunity i
misread
her at the house you know i think that
um if i would have handled our
relationship a little differently than
maybe she would have had a better
understanding of how to
navigate what i'm looking for in a woman
and maybe she would have had a more
positive experience so
i take part of the blame for that not
just being more
aware of uh what was going on wow
that's very big of you matt to take part
of the blame for her behavior
um a lot of people are watching and
victoria is so wild that a lot of people
are watching and wondering
if you were influenced by producers to
keep her around
what would you say to that the producers
they're there for you to bounce ideas
off of they don't
tell you what to do and what not to do
and uh that's what i would say to that
you know
um up until uh
that episode i really didn't know what
was going on and
uh once it was made clear to me then the
decision was
relatively easy look the women tell all
is coming up
and i wonder this about victoria how do
you think she'll be
up there on that stage do you think she
sees
any of the realities of her do you think
she'll own it okay you just can't stop
laughing
what do you think man
okay i can't i don't know lord i don't
know
i don't know what to expect i i am
i don't know what to expect the very
worst
you know i don't know i don't know i
would hope that at this point
um watching it back you kind of have a a
better grasp of
um of your actions and maybe
accountability for some of the name
calling and whatnot
but um you know the bar is very low
unfortunately but i'm hoping that
i'm hopeful you know i i would like to
be pleasantly surprised but
i'm going to manage my expectations
there were there any red flags do you
wish you'd sent her home sooner
uh no i don't have any regrets you know
i think everything happens for a reason
and uh everything that took place last
night
uh is in line with where we're at
and everything going forward is gonna be
a little bit more smooth sailing and
we're going to focus more on these
love stories let's talk about some of
the love stories you said you were
falling in love with rachel cause you
and rachel had both
said you've never been in love before
and then you both said you were falling
in love with each other
how did you know you just know you know
it's like
i think that first group date is when
she really caught my eye when we had the
uh bridezillas and i saw a different
side of her
who's got the red heart who's got the
red heart rachel got it you know i saw
the competitor i saw things that i
hadn't seen in her that first night
things i saw a lot of women i hadn't
seen and from that moment on
we just shared a few moments that might
not have been highlighted due to
what had been going on with victoria and
other women in the house but
uh this has been a steady progress that
had been a steady progression since the
first week
okay and um but there were some moments
we didn't see on tv
so you were falling in love with her at
that moment
yeah you know again it was a feeling i
hadn't felt and
uh you asked about the producer's
influence like this is nothing that
they're telling me to say or do it's
just
i felt it in the moment and um i had
never felt that before
i felt it before you know and and i
hadn't had that one-on-one time with
rachel all of our time had been spent
and um in that group date setting so
having that one-on-one time just
affirmed how i felt and
how she was feeling which was nice you
know i hadn't felt it
yeah to feel that for the first time
ever that is pretty amazing matt
um some eagle-eyed fans have noticed
that you
seem to be listening to rachel's spotify
playlists what does this mean are you
and rachel
together right now there's a lot of
music that
i've taken from a bunch of women on the
show i've listened to kids playlists
i've listened to michelle's playlist
i think that people are very
eager to find any tea and um you know
i uh i lucky for me i had a very
good group of women and i've taken a lot
of what i've i've learned from them and
applied it to my life
a lot of this shirt was inspired by kids
fashion you know a lot of
things that i'm doing going forward were
taken
from okay with these women so i have to
ask you a tough question about rachel
also some fans
and viewers have been saying that she's
been
liking some racist photos on instagram
and have pointed out some things about
our social
media what do you say to that have you
spoken to rachel at all about any of
this
i haven't spoken to anybody since the
show ended but
i would say that you know
there's uh you got to be very careful
about what you're doing on social media
and i think that um
a lot of times kind of what we dealt
with last night
is you hear something on the internet
and
it's fact so i would just warn people to
be careful about making accusations
before
uh someone's had a chance to speak on it
because again we saw how that
happened with uh with brittany and anna
in last night's episode and
and rumors are dark and they're nasty
and they can ruin people's lives so
um i would give people the benefit of
doubt and hopefully
um she'll have her time to to speak on
that fans have really rallied around
katie they love her there are some
people crying for her to be the next
bachelorette what do you think of that
i mean again you saw night one the type
of woman katie is
she isn't gonna be afraid to be herself
and you've seen that with the way that
she's
handled her business you know i um it's
no secret that
she's still around and again with people
being patient to see how everything
plays out
um katie will get half her time and
having a woman like that in the house
made the experience better for everybody
your season has had the chance to
showcase some really powerful
conversations
michelle talks about george floyd
chelsea discussing her hair
how does it feel for you to have some of
those conversations play out on the show
i think it's important because that's
that's the world we live in
those experiences make up
the united states they make up my love
story they make up the women that i
pursue
and without their stories then it
wouldn't be an authentic journey for me
to find love
gotta ask about tyler cameron coming
what can you tease about that
we we had a little surprise in store for
tyler that he wasn't aware of
so i would keep your eyes open for that
next week and
uh it was probably uh that was probably
one of the highlights of
my time there is having your best friend
there and potentially involved in
something bigger than
a conversation with me all right and
we're gonna see one more familiar face
heather is coming
hi chris i was in shock you know and i
think that
people will be very interested to see
how that plays out as
um i've got a very strong relationship
with hannah
and heather is one of hannah's best
friends so it was a very interesting
week any last words you want to leave
with us about your season and what we
can expect just a message around
rumors and bullying um you know
when you make accusations about somebody
that have no merit it's dangerous and
i would just encourage people to to be
smart with their words and make sure
that
um they don't believe in everything they
see in here on the internet because
uh those are the times we're living in
we kind of watched like a learning
moment on the show though because you
handled the resolution of it
yeah absolutely and i was just saying in
general just uh everyone has a story and
i would just
uh be receptive to that and
that's all you